it was hard I think for some of my
students to wrap their brain around the
fact that a Western society people that
look just like them lived like this
I have Nick Gillespie and today we're
talking with Jim Abbott about his new
exhibition in Philadelphia for the
Philadelphia International Festival of
the Arts
it's called Berlin landscape of memory
we're in a room filled with photographs
from Berlin from before the wall went
down in the late 80s to 2012 talk a
little bit about the wall and obviously
it separated the city had separated East
from West free from totalitarian how did
people chew on the West at least how did
they transform the wall it was a vehicle
for communication but then you also had
artists that came that that sort of did
projects on the wall that drew attention
to it yeah and you've talked about when
people tried to do something
aesthetically pleasing on the wall
people would draw a white line yeah
there was literally a white mind it's
just with a big brush that would go all
the way through it and I was told that
that was to negate the aesthetic nature
of the wall so I mean that was a way of
saying don't turn this into an oh that's
right there's nothing beautiful or
artistic about them right if we take
this more seriously than you but there
was a quasi acceptance of it in everyday
life there had been so many
accommodations between East and West so
that the cities could function that it
was just bizarre how do how do Berliners
remember the wall well it's interesting
because there was that whole series of
news reports a week and a half ago about
parts of the East Side Gallery that
they're now removing for development and
that was where the pictures of the Beach
Club were taken it was clear to me in
listening to the activists that has
shown up that some people now they
weren't what's they are there they don't
want any more of it to disappear what's
the motivation there is that they don't
you know they don't want to lose the
past and the horror of the past or they
don't want to see things change as a
kind of concession to capitalism or free
enterprise well
those neighborhoods have always been
probably the most anti-capitalist of
west-berlin there is a population in
berlin that warrants the reminder and
the thing about the esight gallery was
that was a place that became a tourist
site and a reminder it wasn't a planned
place in other words there now all these
strategic places you can go and learn
all about the wall and they've rebuilt
it in places and they have museums and
they they mark the sidewalks and so on
but this was something that kind of grew
out of the people to begin with how do
you head of Berliners remember communism
and the GDR what I found amusing was
enough time has passed that there was a
sense of humor about a lot of it like
you can go to Berlin now and you can
rent a tour of Berlin in a two-cycle
Trabant which was their car one of two
cars you could own and you see strings
of 12 of them driving through Berlin
with a tour guide there's a large
building that had been a GDR apartment
house that has been converted into a
hotel near the train station where
everything in it is GDR so there's this
even listening devices yeah but what's
what's the message of looking at Berlin
before the wall was pulled down and now
after years it's it's remarkable to
think that it was a bloodless revolution
I mean that in this day and age is
extraordinary - that the wall was really
a culmination of of decades of German
history if not a hundred years it was so
absolute in its kind of metaphor of the
differences and it was where the two
systems met so one it was illustrative
to me here or two ideologies represented
in cement if you want to debate the
ideologies look at the differences here
some people would say look we're at a
terrible economy now and you know
capitalism has failed what's the value
of
of remembering that kind of you know
true head-to-head clash between a kind
of free enterprise system or capitalist
system and a communist system it was
interesting I brought my class down to
see the show and some of the questions I
got surprised me because they had no
idea that there could be a society like
the GDR where travel was verboten you
know you weren't gonna travel you your
relatives lived a hundred and fifty
yards from you and you were not going to
see them it was hard I think for some of
my students to wrap their brain around
the fact that a Western society people
that look just like them lived like this
in and it was not that long ago and
we've been talking with Jim Abbott his
new exhibition is Berlin landscape of
memory it's part of the Philadelphia
International Fine Arts Festival thank
you Jim thank you
you